what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and it looks like we have a lot more
plot details about Captain America for
Brave New World we're learning more
about Sam Wilson's new role as the new
Captain America in the MCU and his
conflict with Harrison Ford's
Thunderbolt Ross who will indeed be the
president of the United States in
Captain America 4 but of course he's
also going to be according to all of the
reports that we've heard Red Hulk and
the president Thunderbolt Ross Red Hulk
and Sam Wilson's Captain America are not
going to be on the same side publicly
yes for a little bit but it looks like
we have now figured out why Sam Wilson
is going to start to recruit the new
Avengers team in Captain America Brave
New World and actually go up against
Thunderbolt Ross we'll break down this
new report and the plot details we know
in this video and big thank you to
DraftKings for sponsoring this video
more on them in a bit so today's report
is coming from The Insider can we get
some toast they've had a great track
record with scoop so far and they
tweeted out today where is Captain
America in the MCU the answer to that
question can be found in Captain America
Brave New World and that actually is a
fair question because at the end of the
Falcon and the Winter Soldier it kind of
made you wonder what exactly was going
to happen next with Sam Wilson and his
role of Captain America but the Tweet
continues to state to put simply he's
been benched president Ross thinks Sam's
time as Captain America is better suited
for publicity while Sam knows he is
meant to be in the field and that is
just the tip of the iceberg to their
conflict now right away something that
is really interesting about this tweak
hearing about Sam Wilson's new Arc of
Captain America in the MCU is that it is
actually kind of the same Arc that Steve
Rogers had when he first became Captain
America himself when he first started
off this was his exact Arc he was
basically used for publicity he
basically went around putting on a show
for everybody but of course Steve Rogers
wanted to be in the action he wanted to
be in the field he was a soldier in his
heart and the same is true for Sam
Wilson he was a soldier before he's
still one today he still was one when he
fought alongside of Captain America
through all of the events in the MCU and
that's the story arc that we're going to
go down now plus not to mention Sam
Wilson was an Avenger he is an Avenger
he fought with the Avengers to defeat
Thanos and he is now going to be the new
leader we presume of the new Avengers
team and based off of what we've heard
so far from insiders Sam Wilson is going
to get his own group of Avengers to take
on Thunderbolt Ross this film is going
to be kind of a mini Avengers film much
like Captain America Civil War was but
of course the big question is why is
Thunderbolt Ross trying to bench Sam
well that's where all the Red Hulk stuff
comes in since Thunderbolt Ross has been
in the MCU we've pretty much known that
he's not exactly up to all good things
in fact we know that he does some pretty
Shady stuff stuff that Captain America
is probably not going to be okay with
especially when it involves the super
soldier serum that was kind of a big
part of the Falcon and the Winter
Soldier Sam Wilson is not going to take
a super soldier serum and we know that
in this movie he's still not going to
take one and that's probably a pretty
big problem for president Ross because
he has been about recreating the perfect
super soldier serum for a pretty long
time now and no doubt that he wants that
program to continue and we know that Sam
Wilson is going to have a problem with
that so in order to get Sam Wilson out
of the equation and basically have him
not ask questions or expose him he's
going to put him on the sideline in
hopes that he stays out of the way but
of course we know that's not going to
happen we know Thunderbolt Ross is still
conducting experiments for the super
soldier serum trying to perfect it and
we know that he himself is most likely
going to conduct an experiment on
himself in fact it looks like we might
actually know how and why Thunderbolt
Ross becomes Red Hulk can we get some
toast also reported a handful of days
ago on September 3rd they tweeted on
Twitter or X the hash Captain America
Brave New World with the eyes emoji and
a picture of a heart having a heart
attack with blocked arteries and muscle
damage and what everybody believes that
they're hinting at here is that
Thunderbolt Ross is going to have a
heart attack and in order to save
himself from dying from the heart attack
he's going to inject himself with the
super soldier serum that him and his
team have been working on turning him
into the Red Hulk this is seemingly how
we are going to get red Hulk in the MCU
and once he is Red Hulk it's a complete
GameChanger because before he could do
whatever he wanted because of the power
that he had because of the position that
he held with the US government and now
he's going to be president so he's got a
lot of authoritative power but now he's
going to be a Hulk who has the physical
power to essentially do whatever he
wants so now the most powerful man in
the country the president is going to be
one of the most powerful superhumans on
the entire planet and there's no doubt
that with that type of power comes great
responsibility that Thunderbolt Ross
probably isn't going to be too
responsible with and that's where Sam
Wilson's Captain America and the new
Avengers team comes in and this is where
our mini Avengers film starts to happen
more on that in just a bit but first
thank you to DraftKings for sponsoring
this video DraftKings rain makers
football is back for its second season
and it's bigger and better than ever
before if you head to draftkings.com /
audio you can sign up to play rain
makers today using Code Cosmic for your
share of over $30 million in prizes this
football season and this week new
customers can claim their first pack of
digital players cards for free to get
started playing rain makers football is
simple each DraftKings digital card
represents an athlete and scores points
based on their real world performance
draft them into weekly contest for your
shot at a share of $30 million in prizes
and one of the best parts is rain makers
contests require no fee to join as long
as you have enough cards to complete a
lineup rip packs build your collection
and earn big rewards so wondering how to
get started new customers can visit
draftkings.com aot toay and use promo
code Cosmic to claim a free starter pack
again only at draftkings.com audio with
code Cosmic so Sam Wilson's Captain
America is obviously going to realize
that something is up with Thunderbolt
Ross and it looks like he's obviously
going to discover that Thunderbolt Ross
has either re started or made some sort
of a new super soldier program he had a
lot of authority before but now that
he's going to be the president he's
going to have a lot of power behind him
to create this program again whether
that is government sanctioned or not but
obviously it's extremely hard to go up
against the president of the United
States especially if he is a Hulk and
that is exactly why Sam Wilson is going
to need help and who is he going to turn
two for help well his Avengers buddies
and all of a sudden it seems like we're
back at the Times where The Avengers
were not friends with the government
like the times during the sovia Accords
where half of the Avengers including Sam
Wilson went on the run and were
fugitives of the law but that's really
what Captain America is about standing
for what is right and it sounds like
that is exactly what is going to be
happening in this film Sam Wilson does
not believe in the super soldier program
that is why he himself has not taken the
super soldier serum and now that
Thunderbolt Ross the president of the
United States has started this program
up again and has started experimenting
on humans that doesn't sit well with Sam
so here comes the new Avengers team who
we assume is going to be the same
Avengers roster that is going to appear
in Avengers King Dynasty and what we
expect that roster to look like is Sam
Wilson's Captain America Spider-Man of
course one of the hulks either mark
ruffalo's Hulk or She-Hulk maybe in
hopefully Daredevil since there's a
connection there with She-Hulk and of
course we are getting Daredevil Born
Again Doctor Strange right now is
currently trying to fix an incursion
with Clea in a different universe so
we're Assuming he's not going to be a
part of the team at least not in Captain
America Brave New World so I don't
expect him to come but perhaps Wong
because we know Wong is going to play an
important role moving forward in the MCU
Brie larsson's Captain Marvel is
probably a little bit too powerful to
include in this movie because she could
simply do whatever she wants if they
need a bust into some place well she can
just bust in plus not to mention she is
probably dealing with the events that
are happening in the Marvel so she's
probably pretty tied up at the moment so
don't expect her but we have Ant-Man who
of course has dealt with King recently
and was on the side of Sam and Captain
America Steve Rogers Captain America
that is before Hawkeye and Kate Bishop
could join and we do expect them to be
in Avengers King Dynasty and Ro is
somebody who could join Ro has been gone
for a while probably since the events of
Civil War because a scroll took his
place but he could come back and not
really like how things are going and
really not like Thunderbolt Ross and the
fact that he has restarted the super
soldier program so I could definitely
see him joining the fight and this
leading to armor Wars Thor probably
won't join and he probably doesn't care
too much about the politics of Earth but
we could get shangqi perhaps this could
be his first Avengers outing and we are
assuming that Loki isn't going to show
up due to everything happening in season
2 and the Scarlet Witch is currently
gone so she's not going to show up as
well so it looks like that could
probably be our Avengers roster for
Captain America Brave New World so let
us know what you think about that roster
in the comments down below and about the
fact that Thunderbolt Ross as president
is probably doing some shady stuff and
now it's up to Sam Wilson's Captain
America the rest of the Avengers to go
and stop him do you like this story or
not let us know all your thoughts in the
comments down below don't forget to like
this video And subscribe so you can stay
up to date on the MCU you can always
follow us on Instagram and Twitter as
well and as always thank you all so much
for watching woof
woof